Amigos, Argentina no atraviesa
por sus mejores momentos.
El gobierno de Mauricio Macri ha tenido que
pedir un rescate al Fondo Monetario Internacional,
y lo cierto es que, durante las últimas décadas,
las crisis, las devaluaciones, la inflación
y las suspensiones de pago han sido algo habitual
en la política y en la economía argentina.
Pues bien, en todo este proceso… un planteamiento
político, del que seguro todos habréis escuchado
hablar, ha tenido una influencia casi absoluta:
el peronismo.
Pero, ahora bien,… ¿Qué es exactamente
el peronismo? ¿Cómo surgió? ¿Qué impacto
ha tenido realmente y cuál ha sido su influencia
sobre la Argentina?
Amigos, los vamos a ver aquí en VisualPolitik
en dos vídeos. Y en este primero nos vamos
a centrar en sus orígenes y en su identidad.
Atentos.
¿Quién fue Juan Domingo Perón? y lo más
importante, ¿Cómo logró hacerse con el
poder e influir en la política argentina
durante las siguientes 7 décadas?
Amigos, para arrancar esta historia tenemos
que remontarnos hasta los años 30 del siglo XX.
En aquel momento, el nacionalismo argentino
vivía una época dorada.
La Argentina era, sin duda, la gran potencia
de Latinoamérica: a pesar de la crisis del
29 continuaba siendo uno de los 10 países
más ricos del mundo y los salarios eran mucho,
muchísimo más altos que en la vieja Europa.
Sin embargo... esperad un momento, porque
a pesar de ello, la crisis del 29 había hecho
mella, la crisis había afectado duramente
a este país…
Y en medio de toda la tensión causada, en
1930 se produjo el primer golpe militar, un
golpe apoyado por muchos sectores políticos,
económicos y sociales, sobre todo del lado
conservador.
(Precisamente, bajo todo este panorama de
militarismo, autoritarismo y nacionalismo,
era habitual que muchos oficiales del ejército
argentino fueran enviados a Alemania y a Italia
para realizar cursos de perfeccionamiento.)
Y, amigos, ¿sabéis quién fue uno de estos
oficiales?
Exacto, Juan Domingo Perón, que fue destinado
a Italia, país en el que pudo conocer y estudiar
de primera mano cómo estaba organizado el
gobierno de Benito Mussolini.
Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Poco tiempo después tendría
la oportunidad de poner en práctica estos
conocimientos.
(A comienzos de la década de los 40, Argentina
estaba bajo el control de un gobierno corrupto
y autoritario, un gobierno que había perpetrado
un fraude electoral y que pretendía mantenerse
en el poder a toda costa.
En estas circunstancias el día 4 de junio
de 1943, un grupo de jóvenes oficiales del
ejército argentino, dieron un golpe de estado,
supuestamente con el objetivo de restaurar
un sistema electoral transparente. Uno de
estos oficiales fue el Teniente Coronel
Juan Domingo Perón)
[Por cierto, tras el de 1930 este fue el segundo
golpe de estado que sufría argentina… pero
no penseis que fue el último, para nada.
Durante los siguientes 30 años el país sufrió,
ni más ni menos, que 4 golpes de estado más]
El caso, amigos, es que fue, precisamente
este golpe de Estado de 1943… el que le
abrió las puertas de la política y del poder
al Teniente Coronel, Juan Domingo Perón.
Prácticamente, podemos decir, que aquí comenzó
la historia moderna de Argentina. Atentos.
(LA JUGADA MAESTRA)
Durante los dos años y medio que duró el
gobierno militar, la carrera de Perón fue
meteórica... Y eso que en un primer momento
tuvo cargos poco destacados.
Cargos como el de Jefe del Departamento de
Trabajo, un puesto que en principio era, como
decirlo, poco lustroso, muy burocrático.
Sin embargo, esperad un momento... Porque gracias
a su inteligencia política, Perón consiguió
que este puesto fuera todo un trampolín para
su ascenso al poder.
Veréis, desde el primer momento, Juan Domingo
Perón aplicó todo lo aprendido en la Italia
de Benito Mussolini y lo primero de todo fue
ganarse el apoyo de algunos sindicatos.
(De esta forma, cada vez que el Departamento
de Trabajo tenía que intervenir en un conflicto
entre los empresarios y los sindicatos afines
a Perón… casi siempre los primeros tenían
todas las de perder.
Cómo os podéis imaginar Esto supuso que
la popularidad de este militar no parará
de crecer y crecer.)
El caso es que poco después Perón fue nombrado
Ministro de Guerra y al tiempo Vicepresidente.
Todo sin olvidarse de la política laboral
y de sus sindicatos…
Y es que si algo tenía muy, pero que muy
claro, este Teniente Coronel, es que que ese
iba a ser su trampolín político.
Pero... no era el único que aspiraba al poder…
y tanto protagonismo levantó muchos recelos…
de tal forma en 1945 la cúpula militar le
pidió que se alejara del gobierno…
Vamos que podríamos pensar que la carrera
política de este militar llegaba a su fin....
¿Verdad?
Pues, amigos, nada más lejos de la realidad.
(Perón, había aprendido en Europa la enorme
influencia que los medios de comunicación
podían tener… así que le pidió a sus
superiores, ojo, poder despedirse a través
de la cadena nacional de radio. Ingenuamente
aceptaron y Perón, no iba a desaprovechar
esa oportunidad.
En su mensaje de “despedida”, agradeció
el apoyo que las clases trabajadoras le habían
prestado y puso en duda la continuidad de
los beneficios sociales que él había impulsado.)
El efecto fue total… los días siguientes,
los sindicatos se movilizaron en su favor…y
el 17 de octubre miles de trabajadores ocuparon
la Plaza de Mayo, el centro neurálgico de
la política argentina.
El gobierno desorientado por cómo se precipitaban
los acontecimientos le pidió al propio
Teniente Coronel que apaciguara el mismo a las masas,
Cosa que hizo… pero sólo tras tras acordar
con la cúpula del ejército que sería candidato
en las siguientes elecciones y que contaría,
digamos, con el apoyo de los poderes públicos.
Atentos.
(EL ASALTO A LOS CIELOS)
Juan Domingo Perón había logrado ser candidato…
ahora tenía que ganar unas elecciones.
(Pues vereis, en aquel momento, Argentina
estaba bajo el control de los militares, de
tal forma que para celebrar reuniones se requería
la autorización del gobierno… y los actos
electorales no eran una excepción.)
Por supuesto, los actos de campaña del partido
de Perón eran casi automáticamente autorizados…
mientras que para sus oponentes, en cambio…
bueno digamos que el proceso era mucho más
lento.
Y no solo eso, además, Perón también tuvo
acceso casi total al medio de comunicación
más importante del momento: la cadena de
radio nacional, que era propiedad del gobierno.
Pero ahí no termina todo, el gobierno a instancias
de Perón, aprobó vacaciones pagadas para
todos los trabajadores, así como un sueldo
adicional a fin de año.
[No me digáis que no son buenos reclamos
electorales]
Y aún quedaba una jugada a la que esta especie
de genio de la estrategia político supo sacar
mucho partido. Fijaos:
(El Departamento de Estado de los mismísimos
Estados Unidos intervino en la campañas en
favor de los rivales de Perón, publicando
un informe conocido como el “libro azul”
donde, se daba cuenta de la actividad tanto
de Perón, como de sus aliados militares,
en apoyo del régimen nazi.)
Sin embargo, amigos, Perón consiguió darla
la vuelta al asunto y convertirlo en algo
así como una lucha entre él mismo, que supuestamente representaba la soberanía argentina
y los Estados Unidos.
Al final, con todas estas tácticas, copiadas
años después por gobiernos populistas en
toda Latinoamérica, Perón ganó las elecciones.
El triunfo no fue arrollador, pero se hizo
con la victoria y eso, amigos, era suficiente.
(EL GOBIERNO PERONISTA)
Un dato muy importante: cuando Juan Domingo
Perón llegó al gobierno, la Argentina estaba
entre las 10 economías más prósperas y
ricas del mundo.
[El país incluso era, incluso, un acreedor
internacional. Países como Inglaterra le
debían dinero]
Gracias a todo esto el nuevo presidente contó
con recursos más que suficientes para poner
en marcha su programa político, programa
que sustentaba en 3 pilares:
la soberanía política, la independencia
económica y la justicia social.
En la práctica transformó a la Argentina
en una especie de ejército a las órdenes
de un caudillo, su presidente.
(Cómo presidente Perón nacionalizó un montón
de empresas, especialmente las vinculadas
a los servicios públicos como transporte,
energía y comunicaciones.
Además, puso a la banca bajo el control del
gobierno y aprobó un montón de restricciones
al comercio exterior.)
De esta forma Perón logró un importante
apoyo popular, ¿cómo?
Manteniendo las tarifas de los servicios públicos
incluso por debajo de su coste y contratando
a un montón de empleados para el gobierno
y para las empresas del gobierno…
[Qué casualidad.... los Kirchner hicieron
prácticamente lo mismo]
Por supuesto… todo eso implicaba mucho gasto
público… y ¿Cómo pensáis que lo financió?
1, 2,3…. ¡correcto! Dandole a la máquina
de imprimir billetes…
[Sí, creo que ya sabemos donde comenzó la adicción
de los políticos argentinos por la máquina
de imprimir billetes.]
(El caso es que durante los primeros años
de todo este proceso, gracias a todo el dinero
que se inyectó en la economía, las cosas
parecían marchar viento en popa y a toda
vela…
¿El problema?
Qué, simplemente, no era sostenible… Mientras
el gobierno gastaba a manos llenas… la competitividad
del país empezó a hundirse más rápido
que el Titanic.
En pocos años el saldo positivo de la balanza
comercial, se esfumó; la inversión privada
se vino abajo y de repente, algunos precios
comenzaron a dispararse.)
¿Y que pensais que pasó? ¿Creeis que, dado
que su “revolución” no parecía ir por
buen camino, Perón asumió asumió algún
porcentaje de culpa?
Pues… para nada… lo que hizo fue culpar
a supuestos “especuladores” de estar atacando
la economía nacional.
Y para remediarlo, claro, multiplicó, los
controles, los precios regulados y todo tipo
de medidas que, incluso, afectarán, ojo,
a la distribución de Pan ¡En Argentina!
¡En el granero del mundo!
[¿Guerra económica? Sí, la verdad es que determinados discursos se repiten en el tiempo una y otra y otra vez.]
Pero, amigos, la crisis no era el único problema
al que se enfrentaba Perón… la Constitución
de 1853 que estaba vigente no permitía que
un político se perpetuara en el poder, impidiendo
la reelección inmediata.
Y bajo este panorama,  ¿Qué pensáis que
hizo? Atentos.
(LA REFORMA POLÍTICA)
Junto a las máquinas de imprimir billetes,
el segundo juguete favorito de muchos políticos
son las reformas constituyentes.
Y, amigos, Perón no fue una excepción.
(En 1949, como la anterior Constitución le
imponía muchas trabas… Perón puso en marcha
una reforma constitucional completa. La nueva
Constitución situaba al estado como pilar
fundamental de la sociedad argentina.)
[Incluso en el propio preámbulo de la Constitución,
se incluyeron los tres pilares de las tesis
políticas de Juan Domingo Perón. Vamos lo
que se dice una Constitución para todos…]
Pero, amigos, si quereis podemos echar un
vistazo a los resultados de todos estos cambios:
(La inversión se había esfumado, los datos
macro cada vez eran peor, el país estaba
en crisis y a las empresas públicas argentinas
les pasó lo que a PDVSA… no se invirtió
en ellas, sufrieron enchufismos de todo tipo
y al final… eran muy improductivas e ineficientes…
para perjuicio de todos los argentinos.)
En otras palabras… el nuevo modelo implantado
por Juan Domingo Perón se convirtió en una
máquina de fabricar pobreza…
Por supuesto, todo bajo un  enorme
culto al líder… [y también a su esposa,
a Evita Perón.]
El caso, amigos es que la sociedad argentina
estaba en crisis y tan fragmentada que bajo
estas circunstancias en septiembre de 1955
se produjo un nuevo golpe de estado.
En esta ocasión contra Juan Domingo Perón.
Ahora bien, ¿Pensáis que esto significó
el fin del Peronismo? Pues si así estáis
muy pero que muy equivocados… pero de toda
eso hablaremos en un siguiente vídeo.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Muchas gracias a Alejandro Gómez por toda
la ayuda que nos ha prestado para la confección
de este vídeo. Y también a todos los que
nos apoyais en YouTube y en Patreon.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.